hello mark  so what you've been up to for 20 years  choose life choose Facebook Twitter  Instagram and hope that someone  somewhere cares miss Jimmer I missed you  too sparkly  she was looking up old flames wishing  you'd done all differently  do you still take heroin no and she's  watching history repeats itself  oh thank you  Simon I'm home  choose your future call the police what  shall I say just tell them we're dead  choose reality TV slut-shaming revenge  porn to choose the zero-hour contract a  two-hour journey to work and choose the  same for your kids only worse and  smother the pain with an unknown dose of  an unknown drug made in somebody's  kitchen and then take a deep breath  you're an addict so be addicted just be  addicted to something else  refuse the ones you love choose your  future  choose life